[Musique]
alors apparemment il ya un gros
malentendu sur ma sentence parce qu'on
ne parle de me couper la tête
mais bon on va régler ça en discutant je
maîtrise les amis merci d'être venus
alice est devenu complètement fou de me
couper la tête
non mais son qu'on sait même plus ou
moins leurs idées quoi tout le monde
pense que tu es un connard exactement ce
que vous n'avez pas dit exactement dans
ces termes ainsi si caunes à tapas dix
connards alors moi mais c'est parce que
tu écoutes très peu prendre de petit
bâtard m'avait demandé du changement
dans le royaume
eh ben c'est ça là il est vivant et ça
va changer quand il est mort mais on
avait aussi dit qu'on ne voulait pas
qu'ils souffrent oui mais moi au départ
je voulais l'écarteler à côté de ça il
couper la tête c'est mignon non et puis
à et détendez vous on va faire ça
gaiement on va inviter tous les
villageois à voir le spectacle y aura
des petits stands de bouffe à boire des
oeufs
comment ça s'appelle là le truc à base
de maïs du pop corn
voilà enfin windows bon ça va être super
bon moi je file je vais préparer tout ça
à plus tard
[Musique]
on m'avait condamné à mort j'ai dit
changement il a interprété il devenait
fou mais pourquoi vous demandiez du
changement s'est pas suffisamment
heureux et épanoui avec moi non gross et
palm ou non tu écoutes très pour eux un
tu écoutes sérieusement est-ce qu'un
beau projet devait pas soutenir ma
passion pour le théâtre par exemple
ces fouilles or elle sait pas vers la
tunisie il n'y a pas pu faire que
quelques jours j'ai souhaité une superbe
pièce là c'est un enfant qui faisait
enlever par des loups est dévorée par un
look j'ai adoré c'est génial ça une
pièce c'était vrai ou tu veux dire que
le vieux monsieur est son père ah ouais
ouais je faisais était vachement investi
et où tu vois tu écoutes peu ouais quoi
non là c'est un piège parce que j'étais
avec elle c'est comme quand je te parle
du droit des femmes
j'adore les fans clavier j'adore c'est
ce que je préfère après le poulet c'est
ce que vous faites c'est génial
les potages les condiments autour d'elle
la broderie fêtait ce truc que tu es et
puis descendront crise
c'est fou c'est pas nous c'est vous les
enfants qu'il laisserait une femme avoir
le pouvoir il peut vous l'avez pelouse
est super marrantes en plus nous arriver
à faire des blagues euros merci il ne
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
rigoler bon les amis moi je veux pas
mourir ici d'acord faut pas laisser à
cette sortie que si on est une famille
vas-y partez moi je m'en fous j'ai un
plan où est daniel il a un plan
abelli qui voulait me voir alice je
voulais pas en arriver là mais tu me
laisse pas le choix je te défie en duel
judiciaire
c'est la loi et j'ai parfaitement droit
de demander ce duel
si je gagne je serai libre alors oui
c'est vrai mais c'était la loi sous
l'effet de change est nouveau seigneur
nouvelles règles non maintenant les
duels ça se passe avec des bûches et on
prend les deux duellistes on lui jette
dans le feu et celui qui survit il a
gagné ses plus
dragons toujours intéressé je te laisse
réfléchir fait le malin monsieur je
brûle pas dans le feu dit ce qu'il brûle
pas le sourire d'un enfant
ok donc soit je meurs par le feu soit je
pars par l'épée mais pour l'instant le
plan c'est que je meure pour lui couper
la tête j'hésite entre 7h et cet ep là
je sais plus sûres mais l'épée ça ferait
joli
allez quoi je peux te parler oui est ce
que tu penses que la mort est la
meilleure solution pour désir huawei je
te vois venir tu vas faire au nom le
pauvre de port nyon le il m'a planté un
couteau dans le dos alors déjà je parle
pas comme ça bien épargné mais lire non
pas du tout nan je cherche quelque chose
de pire pour lui que la mort parce que
la mort finalement c'est gentil voire un
peu vulgaire la mort c'est gentil et
vulgaire qu'est ce qui est pire que la
mort de discussions au nom la torture
mais oui la torture mais évidemment avec
un couteau non les petits coups tout
pêcheur la caisse qui sont crades ce la
faute en plein de terre nous ouvrir et
la torture c'est pas pire que la mort ce
que ces délires et les faibles donc il
va mourir tout de suite donc c'est pas
intéressant
alors que si tu allonge sa peine si tu
l'as fait durer des semaines voire des
mois tu peux profiter de ta vengeance
pendant très longtemps c'est quoi ton
blanc l'exil l'endroit où les fous non
ça c'est l'asile est dans l'exil tu le
chasse du château tu le fais partir loin
tu le dépossède de tout tu le mets genre
paysans et tu le regardes se débattre
comme tu l'a pas tué les gens pensent
que tu es un bon roi et toi tu peux te
venger en t'amusant c'est ludique watts
et diabolique paysans c'est bon ça et
leur échappe aux moches
ouais et bien tout crade pourquoi c'est
dans un champ crave il serait pas quoi
faire ouais du coup il baisserait après
ils feraient top tôt dr a bon dos oui
toi pleuvoir
par exemple j'adore
on fait ça
alors bas c'est très humide ça sent ça
sent vraiment mauvais en fait moi quand
je suis arrivé je pensais que ces
toilettes des chevaux et un ces lieux de
vie puis les toilettes mais venir la
soupe d'orties j'arrive compagnon c'est
peu de dire qu'à chaud une nouvelle vie
commence
c'est trop tard pour demander avant
[Musique]